this is from CNN
Uber's diversity Chief is on leave from
the company after criticism from some
employees related to an internal panel
called don't call me Karen
Beau Young Lee Uber's Chief diversity
and inclusion officer is on a leave of
absence according to a uber spokesperson
Lee oversaw a series of sessions called
moving forward at Uber that focused on
issues around race gender identity in
class one of the more recent sessions
was titled don't call me Karen and focus
on the experiences of a handful of women
women leaders a person familiar with the
matter told CNN Karen is a slang term
that usually refers to a middle-aged
white woman with a strong sense of
entitlement often at the expense of
people of color
Lee was put on leave after follow-up
listening session in response to
concerns about the don't call me Karen
panel resulted in additional concerns
so there was a listening session in
response to concerns which resulted in
concerns
and so she was put on leave
um Black and Hispanic workers at Uber
first felt the organizers of the event
were focusing more on the harms caused
by using the moniker Karen then the
harms white people can inflict on people
of color
and a follow-up listening session times
reported some employees felt that their
concerns weren't being heard and that
instead of a instead of a chance to
provide feedback or have a dialogue they
were lectured by Lee about their
response to the initial don't call me
Karen event
okay so there
there were concerns and there was a
listening session about those concerns
which led to more concerns and then they
had a follow-up listening session about
the concerns that came from their
listening session about the concerns and
those also created concerns and so what
we need is that we need now a third
listening session about the concerns
from the listening session about the
concerns from the original
session
we just got to keep we got to keep
listening and keep talking about our
concerns everyone is very concerned
well I'm concerned too and my concern is
this that if you if you still have any
confusion
about
what these diversity initiatives
actually are well this should clear it
up
diversity absolutely means anti-white
that's what it means
all diversity initiatives are anti-white
initiatives
any time you hear about any kind of
diversity initiative anywhere whether
it's in government in corporations uh in
any institution at all
it is an anti-white initiative diversity
is an anti-white conspiracy and you can
clip that and cut it and post it on
Twitter because I know you will because
that's what it is
um and if you ever doubted it well here
you go
because the diversity Chief at Uber
tried to do one thing okay host one
event this was one sessions part of a
series
where they were talking all about
diversity and all the ways that uh quote
unquote people of color are victimized
and in the middle of that series just
one session one little event
where she she tepidly suggested that hey
you know
maybe we also shouldn't use racial slurs
against white people Maybe
you know maybe we shouldn't do that and
just that one time and she was fired for
it the uh the Black and Hispanic workers
were offended they were offended by it
well I've seen all your comments and we
know how much you all are enjoying these
sick Burns during my genucel ad reads
well coming up with creative insults to
uh to you know Target everyone at the
Billy wire can be quite grueling
sometimes even hours of sleep are missed
coming up with ways to make people feel
so insecure that they never want to be
around me again and that's why the
writer of these geniusell Burns also
uses genucel so she never has to be at
wait am I misgendering myself I thought
we're pretending that I'm coming up with
the stuff
anyway he or she never has to be at risk
of insulting herself in these ads and as
she says no one is immune besides me to
catching the smoke just kidding she
doesn't say that she just wanted me to
read that in the prompter
it's a great battery yet again anyways
I've told you I don't do anyways anyway
we don't need the S at the end of anyway
did you know that our friends of
geniusell have upgraded their most
popular package to feature their
top-selling deep firming vitamin C serum
plus Ultra retinol moisturizer with
natural retinal alternative right now
you can take advantage of this limited
time package upgrade for 70 off why
waste time and money to go get work done
to your face when you can just get
genucel skin care shipped right to your
door join yourself secret is a family
recipe for over 20 years that makes it
safe for all skin types perfect for both
men and women made by compounding
Pharmacists and small batches and it's
always safe cruelty free which is so
important to me and also natural so go
to genucel.com Welsh try genocel's most
popular package for 70 all featuring
both genucel's Ultra retinol and
genocell's Firming Serum get a
complimentary Spa Essentials box with
every package order plus free upgrade to
priority shipping go to genusal.com
Welsh you know the first step in uh
growing up and being a real man is
getting off your parents phone plan
getting your own cell phone plan gives
you a sense of Independence and
responsibility it's a step towards
becoming more self-sufficient by paying
for your own finances you learn how to
budget and manage your money there are a
ton of cell phone providers out there
unfortunately most of them want to lock
you into these contracts then tackle on
hidden fees at any chance they get
that's why I'm a big fan of pure talk
there are no contracts no hassles you
can cancel at any time it's very simple
Pure Talk is also giving you a free 5G
Samsung Galaxy phone
when you sign up for the 55 per month
unlimited plan plus hotspot today they
use the same Nationwide networks as
major carries so you get all the same
coverage that you do but a lot cheaper a
lot easier switching over to Pure Talk
is so easy you can make the switch keep
your cell phone keep your phone number
with their Us customer service team you
can make the switch in as little as 10
minutes Pure Talk is so sure you're
going to love your service that they're
backing it up with a 100 money back
guarantee so go to puretalk.com enter
promo code Walsh just say 50 off your
first month that's puretalk.com promo
code walls Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless
99.999999 of all diversity and Equity
material and all training is all about
telling the Black and Hispanic workers
how great they are and how wonderful
they are and how persecuted they are and
how everyone else is out to get them and
they're right about everything that's
99.99 of everything but this was the
point zero zero zero zero zero zero one
percent of cases where it focused on
somebody else
briefly
and they were Furious they just couldn't
handle it
how dare she shift the focus away from
them for 12 seconds
you can't do that never how dare she
suggest most of all that they
should actually maybe treat white people
with some level of basic human respect
and decency
because so that was the really egregious
thing is that not only
did this diversity chief
briefly shift the focus away from you
know racial minorities to talk about
white people but she also suggested that
if you're a racial minority and I doubt
that she put it this frankly but she you
know this was the implication she
suggested if you're a racial minority
you know you maybe there are some
standards of conduct that apply to you
too
Maybe
like maybe you can't just say whatever
you want all the time maybe there's
times when you should also think about
what you're saying and treat people with
respect Maybe
and because she did that she's now um
fired or on a leave of absence anyway
because that's not what these programs
are supposed to be about they're
supposed to be anti-white
it's interesting too to see how um
how vehemently
um people defend the Karen slur and you
know we talked about this yesterday
again they they get really really angry
when you merely mention the obvious fact
that it is an anti-white slur
they're not going to engage with the
argument obviously as I pointed out many
times
if I started calling annoying black
women shaniquas
everyone would agree that it's racist
every single person
you know if I went up to you and I said
man this damn Shaniqua at the grocery
store yelled at me I can't stand these
shaniquas hey shut up Shaniqua
if I said that
everyone would agree that it's racist
okay there would be no argument about it
and this this thing with Karen is
exactly the same thing it's exactly the
same thing there's no denying it
nobody can deny it instead they just
explode with Fury if you dare suggest
that perhaps racial slurs against whites
aren't great because that's what it is
right
they're not really denying that Karen is
a racial slur against white women
because it obviously I mean even CNN
says it refers to white women it's
derogatory it's not a compliment it's a
derogatory label
that is used against a particular race
of people
racial slur so that can't be denied
instead what the the people who object
to my objection or anyone's objection to
using Karen
what they're really saying is that yeah
it's a racial slur but I should be
allowed to use a racial sword against
white women
and not only should I be allowed to use
it but I I will passionately defend my
right
to use that racial slur
and that's what all this is all the
diversity stuff is simply about
establishing and reinforcing the racial
hierarchy that's all it is
we all know it
so um
let's just be honest about it that's all
I'm saying let's be honest about what it
is
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
blocking we become a member today by
using Code wall should check out for two
months for you on all annual plans hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow have a great day Godspeed